[Music]
and careful what you say news be careful
because like sometimes if you say
hurtful things you hurt people and then
you know even though you don't mean it
it can hurt them that's what I learned
recently it takes time okay submitted by
back-up plan that's a plan B [ __ ] Norma
Connell was booted from The Tonight Show
after comments he made regarding loot
Roseanne and louis c.k where he's booted
from The Tonight Show yeah The Tonight
Show was gonna have them on and they
kicked him off actually they actually
had him he was there in Stewie he was
getting his makeup though and Jimmy
himself went up to him and said hey
buddy do but he defended he defended
Jimmy Fallon in that article I read that
article I know it wasn't it was it
the two Hollywood Reporter article was
really good yeah what's going on no he
made fun of [ __ ] people wait wait
really
you hear the down no I don't know I'm
out of the loop yeah article you know
yeah but a lot of people don't all I
know is Roseanne I know I know about
that she got booted but then what did he
do protect Roseanne oh he didn't protect
her he was just a writer on her show her
original show and he was just saying how
he's always known her to be more leftist
like left-wing and like she was the
first person to have a gay couple on TV
like all these leftist thing her old
show was so liberal yeah yeah and so so
he still is like you know that's not her
she cares about one political issue she
like goes issue to issue she's not like
a party what she doesn't do party
politics and she said that the one
reason that she voted for Trump was
because of one issue in particular I
think we were guarding Israel or
something so she's more sense she's more
centrist than anything yes yeah and so
he just said that he wasn't defending
her he was just saying in my experience
I've only known her to be this way and
here's why so I don't see how that's bad
so just in case he doesn't know in
Norman got Norm Macdonald he's the best
oh my god he's so [ __ ] funny he's the
best can you get her of events a little
bit that is the nicest thing anyone's
ever told me thank you
doesn't he have a a new show yeah so
that's why she was gonna go on Jimmy's
show I know more of a comedic actor than
a stand-up yeah same real
it seemed in a lot of movies but I
didn't really see him very much Oh a
stand-up so good watching Netflix but he
defended Jimmy Fallon too because he was
defending how people were coming down on
Jimmy Fallon for having Trump on the
show and I know the hair ruffle thing
and then people were like there he's
humanizing trombonist like well I
thought Trump was human you know and
then and then he goes and also if
Fallon's just like that with every guest
you know why have a guest on your show
if you're gonna hate them you don't like
then don't have them on your show
exactly I don't understand this
go ahead TIFF alright so his new Netflix
show is called Norman McDonald has a
show you know a McDonald has that show
oh where are you being sarcastic no I
really didn't know I did I didn't get
that I didn't get that either
I'm such a [ __ ] mom got good music
with mommy that's mommy yeah so then
alright so he was saying she was
expressing empathy towards louis c.k and
Roseanne Barr because of the whole thing
that they went through and he was saying
that he had Louie contact Roseanne
because of the whole thing like to give
her some support since he has been
through this whole thing of like career
crashing down because of something that
you did so what do you speak it
specifically talking about is how Louie
went crashing because of his sexual
harassment stuff and there Roseanne
being like politically incorrect they
lost everything in a day oh you mean
racist remarks losing your career it's
not like Roseanne me to somebody no no
she made like racist remark she also
made this comment that said something
like he's happy that the me to movement
has slowed down a bit with and that was
said like without any context anything
and so a lot of people just grab that
and just ran with it and like just we're
really upset with him for saying that
and then that's when he was gonna show
up on Jimmy's show it's not a good thing
that the meeting moving us toward that
late so less people are being harassed
right in context he contextualized it
and said that but chris chris hardwick
situation we're like a lady accused him
of some [ __ ] and i'm a they investigated
they cleared him and then he was able to
return to his show like he's glad that
it's not just like hey you're accused
and now you're your careers over which i
think is the me to movement has slowed
down a bit you should just be your
this is the more that he sets a quote it
used to be 100 women can't be lying and
then it became one woman can't lie and
that became I believe all women and then
you're like what that's what he said
so he was just saying like now this is
turning into something where like every
woman has been telling the truth and but
then because of that situation it's like
slowed down a little bit we're now we
can actually look into these accusations
instead of just tearing down the person
immediately so then that's when he was
gonna show up on Jimmy show and then
Jimmy like right before he was getting
his makeup done and everything and Jimmy
showed up to his dressing room and it
was like hey you big old [ __ ] seriously
I mean he came in and said that his
producers were crying and so he can't
have you on the show and I'm like dude
what grown-ass people were crying
because you said you said some [ __ ] like
because you said things about free
speech like oh my god if you read this
article you would not react this way
people read headlines now and people
can't are looking for they draw
conclusions based off of headlines yeah
exactly but it's all sensationalism
right so they quickly they do that for
you to get clicks and then that's why
they try to get an emotional reaction
anything this just proves nor McDonald's
point cuz full point through the whole
thing is that you just these people just
ruin career is based off of of nothing
without taking things out of context and
everything they try to do people lose
their critical thinking skills cuz
you've got all adults like what happened
like no one people used to be more
sensible right and then like did that
just disappear like did they forget
everything that they learned yeah cuz
they took away critical thinking in
schools not just college campuses do
yeah these are all grown people though
what are they accusing him of that he
said some mean things about the me to
movies yeah that he's putting down the
need to movement or so that they
perceive doesn't mean oh I see that's
what they perceived as be people like
twisty what is it what is the exact
thing that he said that made everybody
mad it's the biggest thing that he said
that people got really pissed about that
I don't think we said yet was that the
he said like something about how the
victims of the me to movement didn't go
through that like what Louie CK went
through and what Roseanne went through
the victims of the me
never went through that which is weird
right it sounds I didn't like what he's
talking about
I don't think what he was saying was
like they didn't go through anything as
bad yeah I think what he's saying is
they didn't have their lives destroyed
in a day sexual harassment is
traumatizing and it does affect you
throughout your that's true
somebody stuck if somebody's get their
finger up my ass out of nowhere I would
be like feeling weird for a long time
and maybe like hey man like I could have
done a good video that week but then
like just emotionally never you could
have been viral and [ __ ] you know but
norm was not saying like hey that shit's
okay right and he even said that yeah
well obviously I think that's the thing
now is that people draw their own
assumptions and conclusions based off of
a statement and instead of asking what
did you mean by that or let's look
further into what this person was trying
to communicate reading and writing is
different than your area you know how
many arguments I got into context and I
was like we should not discuss serious
issues over text anymore because of work
here what the [ __ ] are we saying you
know like yeah and you don't know the
Turk what a tone at all yeah why can't
Jimmy Falon honest I really mean this
not a bit like why can't he just it's
like you have the the person here who's
at the center of the controversy let's
have a conversation had the camera we
had the lights he's the nice neutral not
anymore
what about behind the scenes bringing
the producer over the one that is crying
and then hey like let's delay the show
for 15 minutes and we'll just talk it
out because I'm sure you jump to
conclusions based off a headline yeah
the real person is right here let's just
talk it over and is everything cool and
maybe they can stab would make great
entertainment yeah that's not his
persona though you know what I mean
lately his persona he's moved his
persona from being like mr. neutral guy
to - like he's trying to get everyone's
affinity yeah cuz I feel like late night
TV is no longer neutral funny stuff it's
all laughing yes it's super left so
there's really no middle ground anymore
it's so far left to where they think
Roseanne Barr is a is a crazy
conservative that's exactly what's crazy
now you have these centrist people who
are like considered
conservative and right-wingers because
it moved so [ __ ] left and even you
different saying that about makes you I
mean people call me a [ __ ]
straight-up right-wing all right yeah
whatever meet you cuz I'm who doesn't
[ __ ] because I like guns or I like a few
you know things about the right I mean
why can't you pick and choose the ideals
that you like everyone just wants to be
understood right like like that's how I
feel like norm is when he's given an
interview and that's how I feel like I
am and I'm trying to convey a point and
but everyone goes so quickly to the to
the gun and then and to get the tar and
feathers because they can't wait to
misconstrue what you said and often in
politics you're the entire mission is to
misconstrue is to purposely twist
somebody's words so you can paint them
to be something that they're not so that
everyone believes that they're that and
so you stuck them full of enough
stickers where everyone thinks that
that's who they are and then you
demonize them and then nobody'll go for
him it feels like oppression is fighting
oppression yeah yeah yeah there's the
other thing that norm said to that he
got a lot of [ __ ] for it so when he was
already apologizing for the initial
comments he said he was like I never
defended them I'm completely behind the
hashtag me too movement you'd have to
have Down syndrome to not feel sorry for
me to down syndrome not to feel sorry
for the meaty movement yeah and then
they probably got stuck on that like the
arc which is an organization serving
serving people with intellectual and
developmental disabilities they were
like this is so disheartening to yet
again remind the public a public figure
to show respect for people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities of course he respects them
you know like people with Down syndrome
they're like we don't like me to please
the funny thing in the area we're around
a lot of comics and people that are okay
with all kinds of controversial ideas
right so I want to be in this group I
want to see what it's like to be a part
of this like super sensitive SJW world
like what do they find funny they don't
are they always fighting and angry like
what it what's going on you know like
it's like you see all [ __ ] I can't even
show you anything I want to be around
them physically and have a conversation
and see what it's like to be in their
world what do they owe you know what
they find funny puns oh that's some
[ __ ] hey good point that's about it
that's kid job and like anything that's
like ripping apart the other side yes
you know what they find funny it's like
hey trumpet got an orange face got a
boom got him and I'm like yeah I hear
all that so you're talking about that
[ __ ] late-night TV yeah basically
dude it's just like like that Trevor
Noah guy like Trevor no wanna do yeah
anything that smashes on white people
conservatives the alt-right Republicans
Christians I see just so funny because
they're fighting so hard for something
that they're creating like they're
creating even more of what they're right
and it gets people that are on the fence
to be like oh I couldn't see that though
I mean like it's it's if you see
somebody as an enemy it's funny to make
fun of your enemies sure so it's like my
group is better than your bow what's the
joke
where's the jokes at elementary of
course jokes is don't aren't there
anymore it's like it's like a you know
Trump walked across the White House lawn
this morning and he looked fat as [ __ ]
I'm always like weird the joke I just
wanted to see the joke I can't wait to
make fun of everybody I want everyone to
get made fun of but what's the joke man
yeah yeah there's no skill in it right
it's just the easy [ __ ] it's just it's
just cuz it's targeted towards a certain
group of people and you know they're
gonna be tuning in and they love
anything that is that and the same way
on the right I was reading an article
about how stand-up comedy right now is
all more about ranting politically than
about doing setup jokes I've been seeing
yeah that's true I mean both sides I've
seen it all they do is make insults and
think that that's comedy that's it yeah
and the other side's gonna come back and
say wait but like you you were angry
that we were making fun of you now
you're making fun of us the funniest
thing is both sides call each other
snowflake yeah
you both are sensitive called the itself
lakes it's true so true cuz they're
people who are like oh man like I heard
that you know Trump said somebody made
fun of Trump this celebrity made
furniture on pert said some [ __ ] on
Trump I'm never watching one of their
movies again I'm a burden Nike because
oh my god how dare you I'm like what
what the [ __ ] you you are being us no so
an American they're gonna melt this
earth to the ground it's cuz we don't
have real problems
[Music]